previously on the walking hot no buts oh
my god no buts
that's right oh right first bad news is
she's not taking us anywhere the shape
she's in right now gas tanks empty and
the battery's dead
profit sounds like Crawford is the one
place that has everything we need maybe
we should try there what the [ __ ] is a
walker do it inside here inside fast
it's all good let it do did he put it in
here I'll carry it I don't like that
look later something I gotta do
wait you've still got the battery yeah I
think I'll hold on to it make sure you
don't leave without me that's probably a
good idea if I were her Poli how's it
going wrist welcome back to another
exciting episode of The Walking Dead the
combination
well [ __ ] alright huh oh so you two are
staring at a toy by the we'll be trying
to figure out running away from sighs
need any help
thanks but I think we're almost in we're
taking care of Italy don't worry
no little happy little half here shut up
man hi have you met Fred that [ __ ] this
always happened damn well better hey
guys we just want to party we got the
fuel nice gun let's not start
high-fiving each other just yet
let's get the hell back to the classroom
so handle these fuel cans away a goddamn
time
your back [ __ ] love the yes in the
man we made out pretty good - great work
Kenny are you doing with that door not
so good here I'm not surprised you get
that battery yet yeah yeah
Molly has it she should be back here
soon she'd better be
I love the paintings in shed maybe we
can give this to Clemmy creepy ah that's
not let's not do that why we still need
we already got the fuel in the battery
once we find some medicine we'll be good
to go so where's this battery you found
weren't they in the Holloway ran off to
do something well she'd better bring it
back here I don't know why you trusted
that girl with it we hardly know her she
saved your life didn't she huh yeah what
has she done for me lately Wow
come on Kenny no wait there is something
you can help me with something that's
been on my mind I could use your opinion
that I was Kenny this is my hand helping
him work on the boat I've gotten to know
him a little better
uh-huh he's a good guy you know and it's
eating me up knowing what I know I've
been thinking about telling him the
truth babe come on this again been
dominat ball ducking kaca got killed if
I hadn't screwed up back at the Motor
Inn they'd still be alive how am I
supposed to just carry something like
that around don't make me slap you okay
fine
not now not now you stupid [ __ ]
I guess you've got your own problems
look don't worry about it I'll figure it
out I'm gonna get back to this get
Bendis do something useful I don't care
if he's a good guy or not what are these
signs anything they had quite a system
here
Crawford's formal solution initials of a
person's deducting search number of an
eligible citizen found number of citizen
brought to Crawford number of Walker's
found days since our prey
six days only ineligible I guess that's
children older people
okay
I think we know that means what about
Cindy and the other guy aren't they out
in the corridor I don't trust you [ __ ]
oh I can't just go on okay
mother [ __ ] I'm a mother
hi guys what's up
we're so [ __ ] if they get in here wha
step on it must be trapped in there
we're gonna shoot the all of them what
what for you and oh [ __ ] why did I do
that hello hello hello oh nice meeting
ya Oh can't we just do that about every
single time zambese Sammis alright do I
look like it's on video no hell happened
they wandered into the hallway after we
got inside I think they must have heard
us rooting around in here the whole
place is infested
they're everywhere calm down I took care
of them what about the meds did we find
what we need
yeah that's our other problem take a
look enough this [ __ ] again looks like
they were keeping all the prescription
meds in that safe locked up tight
there's no way we can bust it open maybe
with enough time but I don't know how
much of that we have be a hell of a lot
quicker if we just knew the four-digit
combination all right I don't they just
wrote it down and left it here for us to
find we should just try busting it open
we don't have any other choice I think
you get started I'll take a look around
see if I can find anything useful
alright I guess that's all we got to do
that's a bed and I'm out of I did copy
err maybe they copied the code what is
this a copy machine not that it matters
with nope
around here hmm just a bunch of papers
no safe combination though how do you
know that from two seconds I'm looking
at medical file looks like some kind of
medical file and a Korea because she
must have been a patient here and what's
this oh I'd see this stupid camera thing
burden Krista come look at this says dey
need to sense the outbreak
15:47 dr. Logan and consultation with
patient and a Korea why are you
recording this regularly tons o person
has ordered me to keep records of all
medical examinations and consultations I
need you to brace yourself Anna the
sonogram confirms that you're pregnant
oh god oh god oh god
uh-huh as well the rules are very clear
the termination is mandatory you don't
have to tell them tell them dough is
just nausea but you gave me something
for it and it went away this is my
problem
if Overson finds out that I concealed
evidence for a pregnancy I'm sorry but
these are the rules I'm gonna give you a
sedative it'll make the procedure easier
on you I don't want the procedure I want
my baby I can't do Anna you don't have a
choice
not if you like you can take some time
with this but I need you to come back no
later than tomorrow or I'll have no
choice but to inform over son myself I'm
sorry
dammit we almost had it
what the hell kind of place was this
like Molly said the worst card Lee maybe
there's another tape we got to keep
looking I think I recognize that doctor
he was one of the walkers out on the AV
yeah Donna
maybe you should search see what he's
got on him he probably has the
combination [ __ ] alright we're going out
then I would have saved me a lot of time
to do that but let's go out
I really hope we end up on that boat in
this episode I really do we just need
the medical supply fix Ahmed give him
it'll give him a level lovin and then
everything's gonna be alright but he
wasn't dead I really don't like this we
[ __ ] nearly died the nice time we went
here but hey why not go here again oh
stop with the [ __ ] jump scares
[ __ ] yo where did you come from nice and
whoa a TV fell over I'm glad I wasn't me
I don't think you've died from a [ __ ]
TV falling over don't think your head
just I want to live I want to be free
like the butterfly I am how about a boot
to the face you're a better lover aren't
you Oh fatality let's search his pockets
that's another one that would be just
what we need what's the why would we
need like some kind of code
but Vernon said the safe combination was
only four numbers I wonder what I can be
maybe for the locker because then come
on all right let's check this out I
really don't feel safe with our thing
okay this must have been his locker
team safe combination Asst gotta be
rules
what a weird way to hide codes doesn't
really make sense it's not like it's
impossible to find anyway all right
ladies and gentlemen I found two more
tapes one of them is dated October 10th
that's the day after the first one we
watched put it in and it's out of
battery
have you made a decision I thought you
said I didn't have a choice
well technically you do you can
terminate the pregnancy or leave
Crawford of course that would be a death
sentence for both you and your unborn
child maybe that's best I stayed up all
last night thinking about this why are
we even trying to survive to keep on
living if this is what it takes this is
what it's turned us into I don't make
the rules Anna doctor I'm begging you
please help me maybe one day when things
are different you can try again
but for now today we have to do this
he's the opening can he zoom in there
wha no she's crazy maybe this is how I
started it don't fail me who would
happen to Crawford more importantly we
got the combination she lost her baby
too kriste are you all right what's
wrong it's nothing that was just hard to
watch don't worry about me and that's my
face in the background look at this mate
to get the hell out of here
we're in business
antibiotics morphine take as much of
this we can carry okay I think we're
good
this is more than enough for your people
and mine let's go you know I found a
third tape in the locker outside maybe
there's something else on there
we got the meds from Mead that's all I
care about
we'll head back to the classroom don't
take too long Lee oh so I get to watch
it alone that's kind of creepy
I wouldn't want to watch the design be
tape all alone I'm scared not I'll do it
and then we'll end this episode what
listen
oh this was I have to put a stop to this
little arrangement this is the last I
can give you why Overson had someone
down here yesterday taking inventory
he's really cracking down I just can't
risk it we had a deal yes we had a deal
we don't anymore
my sister needs this medicine without it
shall die or she'll start showing
symptoms and they'll take her away I
can't let that happen
I'm sorry Molly I've done all I can but
I have to look out for myself here yeah
that's the Crawford way isn't it